welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to html
grammar and vocabulary in human and
computer languages
so at this point you know that html
stands for hypertext
markup language and we spent some time
talking about what hypertext is and
we've spent some time talking about
market
what about languages now of course we
all have an intuitive idea of what
language is but
like what is the relationship between a
computer language and a human language
is it the same thing
and so that's what we're going to talk
about now we're also going to learn some
new grammar rules for html so
stay tuned for that okay so both
computer languages and human languages
are the same and that they're both used
for communication but of course
one of them we're communicating with a
human and the other one we're
communicating with the computer so how
does that play out
well when we're learning a new human
language
there's two different things that we
need to learn we need to learn what the
grammar rules are for that language and
we need to learn vocabulary for the
language
and the same thing's going to happen in
computer languages
we refer to the grammar rules as syntax
and we think about
vocabulary as being similar to the
computer science concept of semantics
and for human languages vocabulary is
arguably the more important of the two
so you know if i'm stuck out somewhere
and i don't speak spanish and i say
banyo donde
people will figure out what i'm trying
to say or if i'm
somewhere in japan and i say toire dokko
you know my grammar may be off but
people will figure out what i'm trying
to say and if they want to be helpful
they'll point to where i need to go
now unfortunately for computer languages
the grammar must be perfect
that's less true for html where you can
kind of get away with some stuff
for the cascading style sheets which are
going to be teaching you next lecture
your grammar needs to be close to
perfect and when we get to programming
languages
your grammar absolutely has to be
perfect
you can kind of think of it as some
countries or some regions have a
reputation where
if your grammar isn't perfect even
though everybody knows you're looking
for the bathroom they're still going to
say
well i'm going to ignore you because
your grammar's not perfect well that's
what the computer is like
computer will be like i know you're
looking for the bathroom because i
totally understand what you're saying
but like
your grammar's wrong and so i'm just
gonna sit here and not do anything
that's what the computer is gonna do
okay there is some good news when
learning computer languages versus human
languages
and that is the grammar is actually
pretty simplified for computer languages
compared to human languages
which can have some pretty squirrely
rules and
the vocabulary is also much more limited
how limited well it turns out for html
there are fewer than 120
html elements and some of those are
pretty specialized so
here's some examples of some elements
which most of you will never ever need
to know about
so the bdi and bdo elements are used to
reverse text directions so this is
important when you're working with
certain languages
and particularly if you have a web page
that has languages that go
left to right and then you have quotes
from languages that go right to left but
like
how far are you going to make those web
pages so you know if you're a language
specialist
you might need these tags but the rest
of us are like
no we don't need to know about these
tags or elements
wbr i didn't even know this existed so i
went on the web page to count out how
many tags there
are actually in active use uh this is
used to
determine where to break a word so like
let's say you have a really long word
like supercalifragilist be
expialidocious and you're trying to tell
the computer
if this does not fit all in a single
line
where should i put the line breaks well
that's what the wbr is for
yeah i've never used it and then track
this is used to indicate subtitles for
audio
you might use it but like i've never
actually put audio on a webpage before
um so you know depending upon what
you're planning to do with your web
pages yeah it might actually be quite
useful but for most of us
not so much so there's a bunch of these
that
aren't very important and then there's a
bunch of them that are super obvious so
like
the p for paragraph okay that's pretty
obvious
article that's used to create an article
like for example if you've got a bunch
of
articles in your blog section that's
used to create a section
so some of them are totally
straightforward and
some of them aren't used at all so it
turns out there are 120
that's a moderate amount but it's not a
huge amount and
a lot of them are super easy or not
going to be used so
the total vocabulary for html is
actually pretty small
okay and we've learned some grammar
rules for html and again
in computer science we refer to these as
syntax rules
so for example we learned that html uses
tags
that the tags were compared with start
text and tags
that the tags indicate elements so
remembered element is
basically the start tag the end tag and
the contents
we learned that there's different rules
for combining tags
and that tags must be fully nested so
that italic tag must be completely
contained in the bold tag
or the bold tag must be completely
contained in the italic tag we can't
sort of mix the two but what about some
more
grammar rules or more syntax rules um
are there rules for how the elements can
be nested
like which elements can go inside which
so we said the italic can go inside the
bowl the bowl can go inside the italic
what if i want to combine an h1 remember
that's the largest size header with an
italic are there rules for how that
works
and the answer is yes unfortunately
as of html5 they've gotten more complex
the html4 rules are much simpler so
i'm going to start off by talking a
little bit about how the html4 rules are
and you can kind of think of this as a
good rule of thumb
and a good way of thinking about things
so maybe sort of the equivalent of the
english
i before e except after c which is a
rule that
people learning english sometimes here
and it mostly works except for when it
doesn't
and so this is a good way of thinking
about things and mostly this will lead
you in the correct direction
okay so in general there's two main
types of tags
there are what are referred to as text
level tags these are sometimes referred
as
inline tags and these are tags used to
indicate information about a word or a
couple of words within
a larger say paragraph so the bold tag
and the italic tag are examples of this
so
there's also this subscript tag and the
superscript tag which
you might use if
if you're creating a document about math
but you know
many of you won't use those but anyway
so there's a bunch of these tags that
are designed to take
a couple words a couple letters and do
something with them
those are called text level or inline
tags and then the other block level tags
the block level text as the name
sort of suggests are used to create
blocks of text so this would be like the
h1 remember that's our largest size
header the h2s
h3s all the headers the paragraph tag
and other tags um we'll see there's like
table tags create tables
there are tags create lists of items
these are all block level tags
there are also a set of tags that as far
as i know don't have an official name
but i think of as structural tags and
those are tags like the html tag
the head tag and the body tag and we're
not going to worry about those for this
discussion
all right so between the text level and
the block level tags
so if i've got a bunch of text and in
the midst of that text i have a bunch of
text level tags for example maybe i've
got some bold tags and some metallic
tags mixed in
i refer to that as phrasing if i've got
a bunch of text and i've got block level
tags as well as
inline tags in there i refer to that as
flow
and so what we've got is we've got
certain tags we're allowed to place
phrasing in
meaning i can put text and text level
tags
or other elements i can put flow in
so if something's indicated as this can
only contain phrasing that means it
can't contain block level tags
so you can have a bold tag and a tag in
there
but you can't have a paragraph in there
if something can contain phrasing that
means you can have the bold tag and the
tag tag in there you can also have
paragraph tags you can have table tags
basically you can have
any of the tags that actually create
content
on the web page that doesn't mean you
could have an html tag in there or a
head tag and they're a body
tag those those don't count but you can
have any of the
content tags like the bold tag the
italic tag the paragraph tag the
headings
the h1 through h6 tags
table tags that all counts as flow
okay so block all block table level tags
may contain
phrasing so like if you've got a
paragraph you could totally have bold
tags in italic text and
that's totally fine
text level tags may not contain bulb
level tags so
you've got italics element it cannot
contain a paragraph element
we've got a bold tag that bold element
it's defining cannot
contain a paragraph in it that's illegal
some block level tags may contain flow
so here i've got the article
tag as i mentioned earlier article is
used to indicate
um it's going to be used on a web page
that maybe has a bunch of different
articles so an example this would be
if i've got a blog and i've got a bunch
of
entries for my blog on the same page i
could mark each of those entries as
articles and then i could contain flow
meaning
within those articles i could have a
bunch of headings h1 through h6
i could have tables i could have
paragraphs
you know i could put basically anything
within
the article so article is an example of
a block level tag that can contain flow
some block level tags can't contain flow
they can only contain
phrasing and so example this would be an
h1 tag
so remember h1 is used to create a
heading to indicate a heading on
the web page um if i got an h1 that's my
largest size heading
it doesn't make sense to say oh you know
okay so a normal use of the heading
would be like
h1 stanford history so that indicates i
should have a large heading on the top
of my web page that says stanford
history
does it make sense to say h1 um
hey i've got three paragraphs in my
heading and i've got a table in my
heading
and you know i've got a block quote in
my heading that that makes no sense at
all so
the h1 is an example of a block level
tag that can contain phrasing
meaning i can have text and
text level tags so i could have stanford
and then i have
history where history is in italics that
would totally be legal
but again we can't contain other block
level tags in it
okay here's a more complex version
basically the more complex version is
look it up so i provided you with
a handout appendix a from the cs105
course reader and um it doesn't have all
the tags in it i think i've got uh
i haven't counted up but i probably have
about 40
of the 120 tags in there they're a
good start and they're the ones that are
most commonly used
anyway so if if you look at that
document you will see that
it actually lists categories that a
particular element fits in so we can see
here that a paragraph
counts as flow content so remember we
said earlier there's phrasing
and then there's flow and so a paragraph
counts as flow
and you can see that a paragraph can
contain phrasing content so
so far so good that matches our our
little rule that we just told you so
this is an example of the
i before e except for after c english
rule except for it actually works
but we're about to see there's a bunch
of times when it doesn't work
okay this is new in html5 um
and kind of unfortunate but basically
html51 often defined a whole bunch of
new category types
and so you can see that the eight
headings h1 through a6
they count as the flow content okay
that's what we saw before
but actually they have their very own
category which is heading content so
there's things like um
there's an h group that can be used to
create
uh headings where you've got a major
heading and then you've got a subheading
so this would be
sort of like if you have a title for
your novel and then you have a subtitle
that's what you would use the h
group for and the h group can only
contain heading content so it could
contain h1 or a6
yeah it does allow us to have more
interesting more complex stuff but it
just sort of
it just adds a lot of complexity here
basically you now have to look
everything up and you can see here
i didn't quite fit on the slide here but
uh you know article
it counts as flow content but it also
there's this new category called
section content so
there's no easy way to learn the new
rules you're gonna have to look it up
you can look up a lot of them in
appendix a and then if you really get
into it of course
you can look in the official standard
and see what the grammar rules there are
um i did want to mention another thing
related to our grammar roles
and i am referring to them as grammar
rules here and they are grammar rules
but
in computer science we usually refer to
them as syntax rules
so um get used to that name syntax rules
particularly if you learn a programming
language
okay so here's another grammar syntax
rule aware of angle quotes look at these
two quotes that i have here so
in the top chord i say hello everyone
and in the bottom chord i have hello
everyone
but look at those quotation marks the
bottom quotation marks are straight and
the top quotation marks are angled
so the left quotation mark and the right
quotation mark are different
here's the thing those are actually
different unicode characters so
um i'm showing unicode
using the common designation which
actually uses hexadecimal it's just one
of five students you haven't seen this
but you'll see this in a couple days
uh so for now you just have to take my
word for it but
those are different codes those are
different binary sequences so the binary
sequence for the angle
left code is different from the binary
sequence for the
right angle quote which is totally
different from the
binary sequence for the non-angle quote
and
only the non-angle quote is legal
for syntax purposes for html so
be super careful this um you'll also
discover
like if you copy and paste from things
like
pdf files weird things will happen
because pdf can contain
some different interesting characters
there that
perhaps the author did not originally
create so just
be aware of that so here you see i have
two versions of my aahref um linking the
word stanford to the stanford homepage
notice that the top version has the
non-angle quotes and the bottom version
has the angle quotes
the angle quotes version will not work
at all
and again these quotes will often get
generated automatically by word
processors and this is another reason
why i
strongly recommend you use a something
that is a text editor when you're
working with html
that is specifically designed for
programming use as opposed to
something that maybe gets used for text
editing but
also has some features of word
processors because those word processors
documents will think oh i you know these
these angle quotes look really cool
i think that you'll i think you're
really going to like these angle quotes
it's gonna make your document look much
nicer
and then if you're actually typing html
you're screwed
so they do look cool though but don't
use them
bad things will happen okay so
this seems like a lot of grammar to be
remembering
here's the bottom line validate
everything we've mentioned this before
run things through the validator the
validator is going to tell you if
there's something wrong if you've got
those angled quotes instead of the
non-angled quotes the validator is going
to tell you if you're using some html
element in a way that's actually illegal
according to the html5 rules because you
didn't look it up
well the validator is going to tell you
so definitely validate everything
all right so next lecture we're going to
take a look at cascading style sheets
and
we'll really be able to spice up our web
pages and do all sorts of fun formatting
once we've learned cascading style
sheets i'll talk to you then
you